PEGI 16 the city is dying a sickness
spreads throughout the streets a
ruthless Baron rules with an iron fist
bent on achieving his twisted vision of
progress at any cost
yet as disease and suffering spread so
too does a fierce anger this is a city
on the brink of chaos with no Saviour to
be found because for the only one who
can save us not being found is what he
does best
Hey
in theif the next game from the studio
behind Deus Ex Human Revolution you our
Garrett the master thief I thought both
you and Aaron had been killed
after losing your protege and your
memory you've returned to find yourself
the most wanted man in the city hunted
by the brutal thief Taylor general
you'll need to use all the talents of
the master thief to find the truth
before your enemies find you in the
world of thief nothing is out of bounds
and nothing is out of reach
plan your heist carefully choosing which
path you take to reach your objective
steal everything you desire using any
method you choose and use your tools and
every element of your environment to
outwit or eliminate anyone who stands
between you and your prize
the shadows are your only Ally use them
to move through the city undetected but
take great care to remain hidden from
the eyes of your enemies
your bow can be used in a variety of
ways using a number of different arrow
types it's both a powerful weapon and a
versatile tool
[Music]
you can choose to kill
or complete the entire game without
taking a single life employing
non-lethal arrow types and using your
blackjack for silent stealthy non-lethal
takedowns use the cover of night to
explore the city streets at your own
pace infiltrating the homes businesses
and lives of the local people
greed is rampant and clients who desire
your services pay well the extra coin
can be exchanged for additional
equipment upgrades supplies and new
tools as you progress through the game
you'll also unlock new abilities to aid
you on your journey
use the focus ability to reveal the
valuable objects and hidden secrets that
surround you and to swiftly break into
secure passages and strong boxes
[Music]
the city conceals countless treasures
and mysteries that have remained hidden
for centuries
waiting to be uncovered by those who
know where and how to look but remember
even with finely honed skills and all
the right equipment not every heist goes
according to plan sometimes
there are always multiple ways to
execute the perfect heist so choose your
approach wisely
play is a predator using your arsenal to
strike fiercely from the shadows
or choose to play as a ghost using your
abilities to silently infiltrate steal
everything you find and disappear into
the night with no one realizing you were
ever there use whatever means you must
to get in get out and above all evade
capture steal priceless objects and
store the most valuable items in your
hideout high above the city streets
just remember deadly obstacles and
challenges lie around every corner of
the city
as do your enemies whether they belong
to the Barons watch or or something far
dangerous
become Garrett
the shadows
the master thief
you